salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée est
tout de suite si vous voulez gagner un
million de dollars il vous suffit de
résoudre la petite énigme suivante tout
nombres entiers père supérieur à 3 peut
s'écrire comme la somme de deux nombres
premiers ou et l'énigme dans cette
phrase pas directement dans la phrase en
fait il suffit juste de le prouver de
donner une preuve de ça et vous gagnerez
un million de dollars c'est tony faveur
un éditeur de livres qui a lancé ce défi
là de d'offrir un million de dollars à
qui arriverait à donner une preuve
mathématique donc de cette phrase là et
aujourd'hui personne n'a réussi l'énigme
n'est pas vraiment une énigme c'est à
peine une conjoncture et c'est la
conjoncture de goldbach
c'est l'un des plus anciens problèmes
mathématiques non résolus il ya beaucoup
de problèmes mathématiques non résolus
encore ce jour avec des gens qui dédient
leur vie entière à ça et celle de
goldbach est sûrement la plus ancienne
la version que je viens de vous en
donner c'est à dire tous nombres entiers
père supérieur à 3 peut s'écrire comme
la somme de deux nombres premiers est
une reformulation simplifié qui a été
fait en 1740 et un nombre premier qu'est
ce que c'est écoutez moi je vais vous le
dire c'est un nombre qui peut se diviser
que parent évidemment ou par lui-même
comme 1 2 3 5 7 11 13 17 etc
y'a rien qui fait sa foi sa égale 13 ça
n'existe pas et donc effectivement si on
prend un entier père supérieur à 3 par
exemple directement 4 on peut l'écrire
de plus deux qui sont des nombres
premiers 6 on peut l'écrire 3 +38 on
peut l'écrire 3 + 5 etc etc
à chaque fois c'est possible si cet été
vous voulez gagner un million de dollars
vous pouvez vous atlas comme d'habitude
vous pouvez cliquer ou vous abonner et
moi je vous donne rendez-vous dans deux
jours puisque c'est le principe une
vidéo tous les deux jours jusqu'au 30
août
après demain ciao
non